was einfach sehen was wir hier in den
grundschulen was das für die kinder
bedeutet dass wir drehen jetzt über
schließung von acht wochen
wir hatten im frühjahr hatten wir gerade
für die kleinsten hatten wir
schließungen von drei bis vier monaten
und das addiert sich ja alles in der
bildungs biokraft die alles in dessen
kunst schon kind lernt nicht wollen
rechner lesen und schreiben das heißt
das kann bei spielen kindern an schaden
der bildungsbiographie anrichten wenn
sie in zeeland lang nicht mehr los
werden und dieses dieses unglaublichen
schadens muss man sich bewusst sein
hinzu kommt ja auch dass kinder
wirklicher teilweise ihr lebensinhalt
weit gehen fällt ihre schule ist ja so
viel mehr als nur bildung
dazu gibt es auch die vereine sind dicht
ist kann sportlichen angebote mehr viele
kinder sie ihre großeltern nicht mehr
kaum noch freunde für vierjährige das
muss man sich klarmachen wir über
fünfjährige wie können sie denn die zeit
bonner überhaupt nicht mehr erinnern
also nur sicher deswegen genauso schwach
was das für sie sprechen sehr emotional
und eben auch mit den erfahrungen die
sie haben über das thema
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren